et c'est la fin des questions au
gouvernement on refait les casques sur
LCP on refait les questions au
Gouvernement très heureuse de vous
retrouver ici au coeur de l'Assemblée
nationale en direct de cette salle des
départs perdus à quelques mètres de
l'hémicycle de la semaine nationale ou
vient de s'achever cette séance de
questions au gouvernement va revenir sur
les temps forts avec elles amont un Gava
Stéphanie Despierre et Marco pommier qui
se trouve cours d'honneur l'entrée
principale du palais Bourbon à évêque
aussi nos invités violet spielbou
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député renaissance du Nord et Sandrine
Rousseau bonjour merci d'être là vous
êtes député écologiste de Paris on
retrouve tout de suite Stéphanie
Despierre depuis la salle des quatre
colonnes alors Stéphanie vous avez suivi
cette séance depuis les tribunes et vous
vous retenez un échange particulier
entre le député socialiste Jérôme Guedj
et le porte-parole du gouvernement
Olivier Véran sur le bilan des 100 jours
oui un échange assez savoureux entre
ancien camarade socialiste Jérôme Guedj
actuel député PS attaque le gouvernement
et dit vous avez bricolé les 100 jours
avec quel résultat vous promettiez
l'apaisement mais c'est l'épuisement
dans lequel vous avez plongé les
Français et c'est Olivier Véran
porte-parole du gouvernement et ancien
député socialistes sous François
Hollande qui lui répond les socialistes
parlent aux socialistes crier un député
les républicains et le ministre tant
carrément à la main avec une certaine en
phase une certaine un certain lyrisme il
tend la main son anciens collègues cher
Jérôme j'ai la mémoire pour nous deux
nous étions assis ensemble et nous
regardions cette courbe du chômage qui
n'en finissait pas de ne pas s'inverser
aujourd'hui le chômage baise et Olivier
Veyron selon dans une grande comparaison
entre les objectifs ratés du quinquennat
Hollande et ceux qui le considèrent
comme des succès du quinquennat à Macron
et il finit par lancer à Jérôme Guedj
que vous est-il arrivé est-ce que c'est
la nupcisation qui vous rend aveugle au
progrès pour les Français alors là
évidemment bronca sur les bancs de la
gauche même du côté de la droite on
criait arrête Véran et c'est la
stratégie vous l'avez compris du
gouvernement depuis quelques jours d'app
uyer sur les différences entre les
socialistes et les insoumis et Olivier
verront a carrément conclu en regardant
Jérôme Guedj dans les yeux qui lui
souriait rejoignait cette majorité merci
Stéphanie Despierre pour ce débrie font
part tout de suite cours d'honneur
retrouvé Marco pommier Marco vous êtes
avec le ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires Christophe Béchu on va
essayer d'en savoir un petit peu plus
sur ce projet de loi d'urgence pour la
reconstruction après les émeutes
urbaines
oui brigitte a un Christophe Béchu plus
de 850 bâtiments publics atteints de
nombreux commerces ciblés pendant les
émeutes comment vous comptez
reconstruire le plus rapidement possible
ces bâtiments détruits ou dégradés
l'idée c'est de pouvoir présenter un
projet de loi qui va habiter le
gouvernement par ordonnance à pouvoir
rendre possible des travaux d'urgence et
de faire beaucoup plus vite ce qui
normalement prend du temps compte tenu
des autorisations administratives on va
agir dans trois directions la première
c'est sur les règles d'urbanisme que dès
à partir du moment un bâtiment a été
démoli où il a été abîmé si on envisage
de faire des travaux qu'on soit pas
obligé d'attendre de moi avant de
commencer les travaux mais qu'en
déposant une déclaration préalable on
puisse tout de suite faire les travaux
idem si les règles d'urbanisme ont
changé qu'on puisse le reconstruire à
l'identique sans être obligé d'aller
modifier la totalité des plans ça c'est
pour la partie urbanisme ensuite il y a
une partie au titre de la commande
publique l'idée c'est de garder des
mises en concurrence d'entreprises mais
de plus être obligé d'attendre les 50
jours pour faire la publicité pour
publier dans un certain nombre de
documents et donc de pouvoir aller très
vite on pense en particulier les écoles
plus de 80 écoles qui ont été touchées
et il y a plus 80 jours pour faire en
sorte de pouvoir conduire une partie de
ces travaux et puis enfin il y a
l'accompagnement financier une
collectivité locale elle paye la TVA
mais la récupère un an plus tard ce que
le gouvernement propose c'est que la
collectivité puisse récupérer la TVA
aussitôt après l'avoir versé si elle
fait des travaux sur ses bâtiments
endommagés et puis qu'elles ne soient
pas obligées d'apporter au moins 20% de
financement comme c'est le cas
normalement pour toutes les opérations
publiques
très rapidement à combien vous estimez
le coût de cette reconstruction le coût
de ses dégradations on est en train de
le chiffrer il faut bien comprendre
qu'il y a d'une part ce qui va relever
des assureurs des assurances sur
beaucoup de bâtiments et puis le reste à
charge qui dans un certain nombre de
collectivités peut correspondre à des
franchises ou à des bâtiments qui ne
sont pas assurés parce qu'une commune à
la différence d'une entreprise elle
n'est pas obligée de s'assurer elle peut
décider d'être son propre assureur et
donc il pourrait y avoir une forme de
solidarité pas seulement d'ailleurs de
l'État on a des départements on a des
régions qui se sont engagées en
annonçant qu'elles donneraient des
crédits ou à des commerçants ou à des
bâtiments publics et c'est donc Verseau
zéro reste à charge que qu'on souhaite
tendre je n'oublie pas que pour un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens ce qui
pourrait choquer c'est que ce soit de
l'argent public qui viendrait réparer
les dégâts et de ce point de vue les
amendes qui pourraient être prononcer
les travaux d'intérêt généraux auxquels
un certain nombre des émeutiers pourrait
être condamnés ce serait aussi de
manière de les faire contribuer merci
beaucoup Christophe Béchu je rappelle ce
projet de loi d'urgence et bien il sera
présenté en Conseil des ministres jeudi
le comportera trois articles et il
arrivera au Parlement dès la semaine
prochaine merci à vous merci pour toutes
ces précisions Sandrine Rousseau vous
venez d'entendre Christophe Béchu est-ce
que ce projet de loi d'urgence de
reconstruction après les émeutes
urbaines vous êtes prêtes à le voter on
verra ce qui contient parce qu'il y a
toujours des surprises dans les projets
de loi qui nous sont présentés mais
accéléré accélérer la reconstruction des
écoles oui évidemment il faut qu'à la
rentrée les écoles puissent être
reconstruites et que les personnes et
que les élèves puissent y retourner
c'est évident enfin voilà il y a pas de
sujet là dessus et si on peut accélérer
la réparation et la reconstruction à
l'identique alors évidemment et je pense
aussi à la mairie de mons-en-barœul par
exemple qui a une nécessité urgente
d'être construite donc oui évidemment
avoir et modulo ce qui a eu en détail
dans le détail du projet de texte mais
oui sur le fond il n'y a pas de problème
évidemment vous espérez l'unanimité
violette spielboot sur une question
comme celle-là de reconstruction après
des émeutes qui ont émis tout le pays
oui sur un tel texte on peut imaginer
qu'on ait uneanimité d'abord parce que
c'est un texte très très opérationnel
qui permet au gouvernement d'agir
rapidement sur les règles d'urbanisme
sur les règles d'indemnisation des
collectivités en fait c'est un texte qui
s'associe à ce que les mères ont vécu
les mers ils ont besoin d'avoir des
signes forts de la justice de voir des
condamnations de ceux qui ont fait ces
violences fait ses incendies et qui ont
dégradé le bien public nos écoles nos
mairies à Lille à mons-en-barœul comme
vous le rappeliez une mairie entièrement
détruite à Lille c'est la mairie de
quartier d'oazemmes un rez-de-chaussée à
Tourcoing c'est une école primaire donc
on est vraiment dans la réalité et
concrète opérationnelle ils ont besoin
de voir ces sanctions et ils ont besoin
aussi d'avoir les moyens de reconstruire
de faire des travaux rapidement
d'obtenir des financements rapidement et
d'être vraiment aidé par l'État je crois
que c'est un moment d'unité nationale
j'espère qu'on le verra aussi au
Parlement et je reste assez confiance
alors les émeutes urbaines ont été
importantes les jeunes se sont donnés
rendez-vous sur les réseaux sociaux ce
qui a amplifié peut-être l'ampleur de
ces émeutes on va en parler avec
Jean-Noël Barrault qui est au micro de
Marco pommier cours d'honneur il est
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications il
va peut-être nous détailler ce qu'on
pourrait faire pour mieux réguler ses
réseaux
oui Brigitte monsieur barreau monsieur
le ministre au plus fort des émeutes
Emmanuel Macron avait appelé les réseaux
sociaux à la responsabilité des réseaux
qui joueraient un rôle amplificateur
dans la propagation à des violences
est-ce que ces plateformes ont joué le
jeu écoutez avec le ministre de
l'intérieur on les a convoqués le
vendredi 30 juin pour les rappeler à
leurs obligations légales retrait des
contenus illicites qui leur sont
signalés réponse aux réquisitions aux
demandes de l'autorité judiciaire pour
pouvoir conduire les enquêtes et force
et de constater que ce sont des milliers
de contenus qui ont été retirés des
centaines de comptes qui ont été
supprimés des dizaines de réquisitions
qui ont été traités que d'ores et déjà
on voit des condamnations tombées pour
des faits de violence en ligne pour des
appels au meurtres de gendarmes de
policiers pour des appels la dégradation
de bâtiments publics de commissariat de
gendarmerie etc donc il me semble que il
y a une forme de réactivité dans
l'ensemble de la chaîne Emmanuel Macron
avait dit la semaine dernière avait
évoqué la possibilité de couper les
réseaux sociaux en cas de tension savait
fait polémique cette déclaration vous
êtes d'accord est-ce que c'est pas
dangereux pour la liberté d'expression
ce que le président de la République a
dit c'est que à froid il avait falloir
évaluer le rôle et la contribution que
certains réseaux sociaux ont pu jouer
dans la formation des événements
violents qu'on a qu'on a connu ces
derniers jours pour ensuite évaluer si
le droit européen le droit français nous
permet de sécuriser les Français dans
dans le le type de situation comme celle
qu'on a vécue ces derniers temps j'ai
donc
constitué un groupe de travail
transpartisans
toute couleur politique confondues qui
rassemblent des députés des sénateurs
qui va se réunir dès demain pour la
première fois et qui va entamer ce
travail pour qu'à la fin de l'été si
besoin si on si on doit prendre des
mesures législatives qu'elles puissent
intégrer le projet de loi que je porte
avec Bruno Le Maire pour sécuriser et
réguler l'espace numérique adopter la
semaine dernière au Sénat examiner à
l'aut à l'Assemblée nationale merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre Merci à
VOUS Sandrine Rousseau le président de
la République au moment des émeutes a
dit qu'éventuellement il faudrait penser
à réguler ses réseaux sociaux voir les
suspendre en cas d'atteindre grave à la
nation qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire là-dessus est-ce que vous vous
pensez qu'il faudrait le faire mais j'ai
déjà été très étonné de cette de cette
phrase parce que supprimer les réseaux
sociaux ça n'est pas bon signe pour
notre démocratie enfin je dans les
suspendes temporairement
ce qui peut se produire dans d'autres
pays et que c'est pas ça le sujet c'est
pas les réseaux sociaux en fait c'est la
cohésion sociale c'est le fait que les
personnes n'est pas à faire ça et par
ailleurs sur les réseaux sociaux je
rappelle quand même que ça fait des mois
des années qu'il y a du
cyber-harcèlement en masse en masse de
certaines personnes et que personne
n'agit c'est-à-dire que on laisse les
choses s'installer et là soudain tout à
coup il y a tout un appareil d'État j'ai
même entendu
Thierry Breton de l'Europe le
commissaire européen il y a un digital
service Act effectivement
que subissent les victimes sur les
réseaux sociaux et là vraiment j'ai été
très surprise parce que finalement ce
qu'on nous présentait comme impossible
apparaît possible mais avec les dérives
de la de la liberté d'expression avec
les dérives de la démocratie et du
respect des contre-pouvoirs et là-dessus
vraiment il va falloir être vigilant je
crois que je fais partie de ce groupe
parce qu'on en a discuté ce matin et je
serai très vigilante à ce que la liberté
soit soit maintenue et que par contre il
y ait des outils qui permettent de de
réduire la nocivité de ces réseaux
sociaux parce que ils sont nocifs et ils
sont nocifs notamment parce
qu'aujourd'hui certains servent de de
support à l'extrême droite pour répondre
leur haine et pour répondre leur leur
violence et leur racisme sans aucune
espèce de limite suspendre
temporairement les réseaux sociaux
Sandrine Rousseau nous dit bah c'est pas
le problème finalement le problème c'est
la cohésion c'est la cohésion sociale la
cohésion des territoires en tout cas les
réseaux sociaux et leur utilisation est
une un reflet de notre société et il y a
certaines dérives qui ne sont pas que
sur un bord politique il y a des dérives
d'utilisation des réseaux sociaux avec
les algorithmes avec les fake news avec
tout ce que font les jeunes et les moins
jeunes pour transformer l'information
l'image et créer finalement des dérives
qui sont extrêmement nuisibles à notre
démocratie heureusement les réseaux
sociaux c'est aussi du lien social c'est
aussi de la convivialité donc on a une
belle opportunité et là on a quand même
un problème de régulation de ces réseaux
unités c'est que on a le projet de loi
numérique qui arrive là à la rentrée sur
lequel on travaille depuis de nombreux
mois en relation bien sûr avec la
réglementation européenne et dans ce
projet de loi numérique il y a un volet
très important sur le cyber-racellement
pour qu'on puisse avoir des moyens
d'action élargi et puis il y a un sujet
aussi sur le bannissement des réseaux
sociaux quand on est banni sur un réseau
social comment on fait pour être banni
automatiquement sur un autre comment on
fait tout en respectant les libertés la
protection de la vie privée pour être
beaucoup plus contraignant beaucoup plus
on l'a déjà fait nous on a fait une
réunion juste au lendemain des violences
en amont de l'annonce de Jean-Noël
Barrault avec des députés Stéphane
vogeta Paul le midi pour recevoir les
réseaux sociaux impliqués notamment Tik
Tok et snapchat snapchat nous a déjà
indiqué comment fonctionner la carte de
géolocalisation sur snapchat et comment
sous la demande du gouvernement pendant
ses émeutes ils avaient réussi à faire
disparaître un certain nombre de vidéos
appelant à la haine et au rassemblement
pour incendier des biens publics donc il
y a déjà des actions qui ont été mises
en œuvre il y a aussi la plateforme
Pharos qui a été beaucoup plus active il
faut qu'on continue en ce sens le projet
de loi numérique ça sera un vrai moment
de débat à la fois sur le respect des
libertés mais aussi sur l'action très
ferme sur la violence sur les réseaux
sociaux alors on va parler à présent de
la présence des députés la France
insoumise et écologiste à la
manifestation interdite pour Adama
Traoré c'était ce week-end question dans
l'hémicycle cet après-midi de la députée
renaissance du Val-d'Oise Émilie
Chandler qui a interpellé le ministre de
l'Intérieur je propose d'entendre la
réponse que lui a faite Gérald Darmanin
les Français dans leur ensemble ont été
extrêmement choqués que des
parlementaires en écharpe puissent
défiler au son de tout le monde déteste
la police
et je veux dire que ceux qui ont défilé
au son de tout le monde déteste la
police sans s'écarter
sans faire un tweet sans regretter ne
déshonore pas la police nationale mais
déshonore leur mandat et la vie de femme
et d'un politique
alors madame la députée plutôt que
donner publicité à des extrémistes qui
crachent sur la tombe des policiers
morts je voudrais ici depuis trois ans
vous lire et j'espère vous faire
applaudir dans l'ensemble cette émission
tous les policiers morts en service et
qui laissent des veufs des veufs des
orphelins
Frank Laboa
Éric Mauroy
Freddy Allard
romain boulange
Vincent Martinez
Stéphane Le meurt
Amaury la Groix de croûte
Stéphanie montfermé
Eric Masson
Wilfried Faron
Steven kreblack
Manon
Paul Medeiros
vive la république et vive la police
nationale
et on va donner à présent la parole à
Aurélien Lopez ligori les députés
rassemblement national de l'Hérault il a
également interpellé le ministre de
l'Intérieur cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle on le retrouve au micro
d'Elsa moringampa Gérald Darmanin a cité
le nom des policiers morts en exercice
vous la présence de députés en soumis
dans une manifestation enfin de député
nupestres dans une manifestation ou des
slogans Antipolis ont été prononcés ça
vous a choqué oui vous savez quand on
est député notre fonction exige un
devoir de dignité d'exemplarité et là
vous avez deux choses déjà une
manifestation interdite ou des députés
nups LFI et écologiste ont participé à
cette manifestation interdite avec ses
slogans qu'on a entendu tout le monde
déteste la police et aussi aux côtés
organisé par une famille un gang la
famille Traoré le gang Traoré avec des
membres de cette famille qui ont été
condamnés pour trafic de stupéfiant
violence outrage pyromanie donc niveau
dignité exemplarité le garde des sceaux
vous a répondu en vous disant vous
pouvez signaler au procureur l'article
40 plus vous comptez le faire pour les
députés présents alors j'ai regardé il
faut que je vérifie mais quand tu
vérifie mais l'article 40 c'est
seulement pour les délits et les crimes
et là on est sur une une contravention
de 4e catégorie donc normalement on peut
pas utiliser cet article 40 mais on va
regarder comment on peut comment on peut
faire pour pour qu'il soit sanctionner
je pense pourtant Marine Le Pen elle est
sortie celle des quêtes colonnes vous
savez qu'il y a des députés de la
majorité qui demandent des condamnations
des sanctions de l'Assemblée Marine Le
Pen non elle nous a dit je suis contre
les sanctions chaque député finalement
est libre de faire ce qu'il veut en
dehors de cette assemblée c'est pas à
l'Assemblée nationale de
donner des sanctions des sanctions sur
quelque chose qui se déroule en dehors
de l'Assemblée nationale c'est déjà aux
Français de sanctionner la nups dans les
urnes et c'est à la justice quand il y a
une infraction ou un délit de d'agir et
là pour le coup il y a manifestement une
infraction merci beaucoup
merci Elsa mon Agava Sandrine Rousseau
vous vous étiez à cette manifestation ce
week-end pour Adama Traoré manifestation
interdite je le rappelle par le préfet
parce que crainte des meute
supplémentaires après les émeutes
urbaines qu'on avait connu il y a
quelques jours dans cette manifestation
certains ont chanté à un moment tout le
monde déteste la police est-ce que vous
vous avez été heurté par ça est-ce que
vous vous dites maintenant j'aurais dû
quitter la manifestation comment vous
réagissez non mais je n'ai
personnellement je n'ai jamais chanté ça
et je l'ai entendu dans bien des
manifestations bien des manifestations
je ne l'ai jamais chanté après je pense
qu'il faut se rendre compte que depuis
les gilets jaunes et depuis la création
de cette brave m qui a été à l'origine
de bien des des violences en
manifestation il y a une défiance
vis-à-vis de ceux qui minifient
vis-à-vis de la police et traiter ça
sous l'angle de on va faire un article
40 on va les sanctionner on va les
mettre au piquet
dans un coin franchement ça n'est pas à
la hauteur du sujet ça n'est pas à la
hauteur du sujet les députés ont une
liberté et c'est fondamentale parce que
c'est constitutionnel parce que il y a
aussi quelque chose de l'ordre de de
du fonctionnement démocratique qu'il
faut respecter et je vous garantis que
s'il y a la moindre condamnation nous
irons jusqu'à la Commission européenne
jusqu'à la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme parce que vraiment là c'est
quelque chose très très important il y a
une liberté parlementaire et
fondamentale maintenant je vous le dis
c'est c'est slogan là devrait être
regardé pour une crise comme le symptôme
d'une crise et non pas comme quelque
chose que l'on doit absolument
réprimer et punir tous ceux qui étaient
en présence à moins de 500 mètres autour
d'un droit constitutionnel de manifester
exactement dans la manifestation avait
été interdite dans ce cas-là est-ce que
c'est le rôle des députés d'être là-bas
oui mais alors ça c'est il y a une
question très importante parce qu'en
effet la manifestation avait été
interdite bon déjà les manifestations
Inter aujourd'hui en France sont
essentiellement écologistes et
antiracistes ce qui pose une question
mais la deuxième chose c'est que les
ministres d'extrême droite qui sont dans
les rues elles ne déposent pas
d'autorisation de manifester et en fait
quelle est la leçon de tout cela c'est
que la prochaine fois est-ce qu'il sera
plus judicieux de ne pas déposer de
demande de manifester et de faire du
coup des rassemblements sauvages qui
finalement sont moins risqués que de
faire des demandes d'autorisation de de
manifester et là je vous le dis on est
dans une dérive et je n'ai pas entendu
les membres de la majorité d'aucune
manière dénoncer les rassemblements
d'extrême droite c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y
a les mots les plus durs possible les
plus dures du dictionnaire pour
condamner ce que nous avons fait je n'ai
pas entendu un seul mot pour condamner
les ministres habillés de noir qui
circulent dans nos rues qui ont
même menacé qui ont terrorisé dans les
rues par exemple de Lyon mais aussi
d'autres villes de France et vraiment là
on est à mon avis à une question
fondamentale c'est finalement
préférez-vous des manifestations
d'extrême droite non à des
manifestations antiracistes encadrées où
il n'y a pas de débordement et des
manifestations écologistes pour le bien
commun et là je crois qu'on est sur
cette espèce de ligne de crête que le
gouvernement n'arrive pas à gérer qui
est que il sont sur l'idée que l'extrême
droite finalement et bien ça n'est pas
si grave alors est-ce qu'il y a deux
poids de mesure finalement entre la
gauche la gauche de la gauche et
l'extrême droite quand il y a des
manifestations et puis autre question
est-ce que vous avez vous ciblez
beaucoup la France insoumise on a
entendu la première ministre on l'a on
l'a lu aussi est-ce que vous avez choisi
votre opposition finalement en désignant
le rassemblement national mais je crois
d'abord moi j'ai été atterré de voir ces
images d'élus de la République de
députés avec leur écharpe bleu blanc
rouge défilé aux côtés de manifestants
dont la manifestation était interdite
mes émotions
je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous je ne
suis pas d'accord parce que les règles
sont les mêmes pour tout le monde et
quand il y a une manifestation qui est
déposée qui est interdite qui ensuite
attaqué au tribunal et où le tribunal
administratif confirme l'interdiction et
qu'on a des députés derrière la décision
d'un préfet derrière la décision
judiciaire d'un tribunal qui vont quand
même à une manifestation c'est un
affront aux valeurs républicaines c'est
pour cela que Gérald Darmanin dit que
les députés qui font cela déshonore nos
valeurs républicaines moi je le partage
totalement et donc les règles sont les
mêmes pour tout le monde quand on essaye
d'interdire une manifestation de
l'extrême droite et que elle serait
autorisée par un tribunal parce qu'il
n'y aurait pas d'ordre de troubles à
l'ordre public suffisamment prouvé par
un préfet et bien il faut s'en tenir aux
décisions c'est parfois très regrettable
mais on a des règles il faut qu'elle
soit les mêmes pour tout le monde
ensuite sur ce que vous dites sur sur
finalement les règles et la violence moi
moi je reprendrai une phrase qui m'a
beaucoup choquée dans ce que vous
écrivez et que vous assumez c'est la
seule issue possible à une colère
populaire devient la violence vous êtes
une des élus de la nupes avec la France
insoumise au sein d'Europe écologique
les Verts qui régulièrement légitimité
la violence l'appel à la haine sous
prétexte de liberté et bien je crois
qu'on meurt de cela dans notre pays je
crois que on a besoin d'élus qui font
unité qui font cohésion nationale qui
montre l'exemple à l'Assemblée nationale
quand on est face à des violences comme
on a fait quand vous excusez les péages
avec la misère et la pauvreté vous êtes
complètement à côté de la plaque déjà je
ne les excuses
je dis qu'il y a quelque chose quand on
quand c'est les Lidl et les Aldi qui
sont attaqués il y a quand même quelque
chose autour du pouvoir d'achat qu'on
devrait mesurer et votre votre
indifférence votre indifférence
votre indifférence à cette question
montre toute la politique macroniste en
fait on est dans quelque chose où on a
que de l'autorité par ailleurs quand
j'ai fait ce tweet sur la solitude c'est
la violence c'est qu'en fait vous avez
utilisé toutes les argus si possible
pour éviter le débat démocratique donc
qu'est-ce qu'il reste à la fin et je ne
le je ne le cautionne pas je demandais
justement à ce qu'il y ait des débats
démocratiques à l'intérieur de
l'Assemblée qu'il n'y ait pas de 49-3
qu'il n'y ait pas d'article 40 qu'il n'y
ait pas toutes les argusies que vous
avez utilisées pour éviter le débat
qu'il n'y ait pas de négation des
trois,5 millions de personnes qui sont
allés dans la rue et donc aucun des
représentants n'a été reçu donc du coup
ça justifie la violence ça justifie
justifie la violence mais maintenant
comment comment fait-on ni ce que vous
écrivez
pas au calme qu'il y a une adhésion vous
vous
êtes des professionnels
j'ai cru que vous étiez assis puis
debout
parce que je suis levé vous êtes levé
pour les policiers je me suis très clair
avec les valeurs républicaines vous êtes
maintenant
Rousseau pardon vous êtes assise non
vous êtes non vous étiez dans le doute
j'ai bien sûr
répondez Sandrine Rousseau je vais vous
dire quelque chose c'est que là on est à
un point de rupture c'est à dire que
soit vous entendez vous entendez que
vous ne dirigez pas la France comme vous
dirigeriez une entreprise et que vous
êtes là dans le cadre d'une démocratie
avec le débat contradictoire avec avec
l'altérité c'est à dire que oui nous ne
pouvons ne pas être d'accord pour autant
nous n'avons pas à avoir une
décrédibilisation permanente de notre
action politique soit vous entendez que
les députés et sénateurs républicains
qui
redouble de propos
racistes tendancieux accusateur alors
même que je vous n'avez jamais eu un mot
de condamnation pour eux là nous sommes
à la limite de la séparation sociale que
finalement vous organisez par votre
pouvoir et ça c'est grave madame
spielbout c'est vraiment extrêmement
grave
tout simplement que Europe Écologie Les
Verts qui défend plein de de
propositions auxquelles on fait
attention auxquelles on peut s'allier
même dans d'un format transpartisan sur
et bien ça va ça arrive et ça arrivera
vous verrez avec la nouvelle exposition
j'en ai un sur la liberté de la presse
dont on va discuter après ou on
travaille ensemble avec vos collègues de
votre groupe désolé je crois que vous
n'êtes pas au courant de tous que je
veux dire
proche de la France insoumise qui pose
aujourd'hui problème à Europe Écologie
Les Verts et aux parties socialistes
elle est dans cette partie de la nups
qui a pendant les réformes multipliées
les amendements par milliers et par
milliers pour empêcher le débat
démocratique donc vous n'acceptez pas
faire tout simplement que vous n'avez
pas gagné l'élection présidentielle que
vous n'avez pas gagné l'élection
législative
sur laquelle on essaye de nombreuses
fois dans l'émission parlementaire et au
sein des débats de proposer des
et on voit que vous vous êtes en
permanence dans l'agression l'eau dont
on vous mettra pas on a bien vu vos
différences et votre opposition je
voudrais juste vous faire réagir d'un
mot à ce que Papen DIY a dit l'autre
c'était ce weekend en disant que c'est
news et Europe 1 était des médias
d'extrême droite relayer cette idéologie
là Sandrine Rousseau vous êtes d'accord
avec ma peine d'yay est-ce que c'est le
rôle d'un ministre de l'Éducation de
dire ça et bien sûr que je suis d'accord
c'est un des sujets
Bolloré ne fait pas se créer ne fait pas
mystère de son projet politique il l'a
même décrit dans un portrait au monde de
manière extrêmement claire les les
rédaction du JDD se bat pour la liberté
de la presse qui fait partie des
libertés fondamentales et là encore nous
n'entendons pas lrem et quand moi je
j'entends les discours des uns et des
autres quand j'étais dans les autres
mais là par exemple vous
ne dites pas que la République en marche
ou en Renaissance ne soutient pas avec
fait passer puisque vous faites passer
toutes les lois en commission des
affaires culturelles casser la
concentration des pouvoirs dans la
presse là en l'occurrence ça c'est
quelque chose sur lequel il faudrait
légiférer la concentration dans la pièce
aujourd'hui on atteint un point de
bascule et il se passe ce qui s'est
passé aux États-Unis c'est-à-dire qu'il
y a des milliardaires qui ont un projet
politique de bataille culturelle et
d'imposition de l'extrême droite au
pouvoir qui utilise les médias comme
étant des vecteurs et des anciens de
leurs messages 10 secondes si vous
voulez j'ai fini un sujet sur le sujet
de de la liberté de la presse et de ce
qui arrive au JDD oui nous devons
légiférer sur la concentration des
médias pour préserver l'indépendance et
le plus réalisme de notre presse en
France le sujet c'est pas de combattre
une presse d'opinion de de droite de
gauche il faut pas tout mélanger il faut
garder l'indépendance entre la liberté
d'entreprendre et la liberté de nos
médias mais la presse les médias c'est
pas une entreprise comme une autre et
oui moi je suis partante pour travailler
avec l'ensemble des groupes républicains
pour un projet
de la formation voilà sur la régulation
des médias prochainement l'assemblée
merci à toutes les deux d'avoir accepté
de venir débattre sur ce plateau merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivis on rentre
un tout petit peu en retard mais on se
retrouve quand même la semaine prochaine
mardi prochain pour la dernière séance